hey everyone Peter Brown here for
another gamespot news update earlier
today Walmart announced they're going to
start accepting used games for both
current and next-gen platforms according
to walmart merchandising chief Duncan
McNaughton Walmart will start giving in
store credit for trade ins at 3,100
stores nationwide beginning March 26th
Walmart believes it's competitive
advantage is that the credit you gain
from a trade-in can be used for
purchases besides gaming such as food
and clothing indeed gamestop can't
compete there but unlike gamestop
Walmart will not have a cash option for
trade ins it's either credit or nothing
at all and on top of that Walmart will
only accept games not hardware this
isn't the first time game stops position
as the primary used video game dealer
has been challenged best buy target and
amazon have all tried to enter the used
game market and none have had much
success gamestop has 10 years experience
trading in used games a massive
refurbishment Center in Texas and a
power of reward incentive program
finally though Nick not never mentioned
gamestop by name during the call he said
Walmart's aim with its second hand
program is to pay more than anybody else
for your old games of course trade-in
prices will vary but he said the average
price paid per title should be around
$35 alright that does it for today's
game spot news update I've got some
games here it looks like I've got about
well about a diaper and rifles worth see
you guys later